[inaudible] [inaudible]
the French revolution does not only
a major event in French history,
but world history.
It's occurrence for a democratic ideals
and reform across the entire Globe and
paved the way for the empire of Napoleon,
which all had a profound
impact on world history.
But what if it never happened to start?
We must look at wine Eventide and before
we can discuss an alternate history,
of course,
it is truly impossible to predict the
changes that would come today and tunic a
major event from such a long time ago
as first in a world where little changes
can have a big impact.
But we will use history and reasoning
to come up with an appropriate scenario.
The French revolution
happened for multiple reasons,
democratic ideals and philosophy.
We're building up in 18th century,
Europe and France,
like barrels of gunpowder.
All it took was a spark
to change everything.
And this spark was Francis failed economy
and it's harsh winter at the time,
well, let's say King Louis the 16th was
able to turn all this around and this
scenario,
he fixes the economy.
The peasants are friends or
less angered democratic ideals.
And not gain as much ground
first and foremost,
part of Louis the 16th ever to stabilize
the economy of all familiar methods and
our own timeline deploy in reclaiming
Louisiana from Spain to sell to the United
States in order to acquire funds for
his army and our own bizarre timeline.
Louie the 16th that's the same thing.
France maintains possession of Heidi,
however,
maintain slavery there until there a
billion occurs face with total loss of the
colony,
Louie the 16th the sides.
It would be beneficial to abolish slavery
in the colonies just as England will
do soon and early 19th century
Europe without the French revolution.
The continent is better with each other.
France and England are still
in constant competition.
England is still bitter with France for
assessing the American revolutionaries
and Francis bitter about their
losses in the Americas. In fact,
all of Europe is still dissatisfied with
the seven years war and their conflicts
which came after and our own timeline
just before the French revolution began.
Prussia and Austria,
we're squaring up for war,
so there are alliances badly weakened.
Austrian friends seeing the thread began
to reconstruct their alliance along
with Russia, Spain in Denmark. Meanwhile,
pressure of Britain in Portugal perform
their alliance this time taking up with
the Ottoman Empire in Sweden as
Britain threatens the United States,
France attempts to convince
the Americans to join them.
At first President Thomas Jefferson
declines wanting America through remain
isolationists.
Eventually though the United States is
forced to declare war on Britain to the
British harassment,
encouragement of native American
raids and for various other reasons.
Thus begins the war of Oh six Americans
facing the blunt of the British army
ally themselves with France,
but France alone plus the
French soon join the fight,
which prompts Europe to
join the fight as well.
The war of 1806 becomes international
and North America conflict explodes.
The French and Americans
fight the British everywhere,
but France predominantly
leads a campaign in Canada,
encouraged by the conflict that people
of Quebec rise up to aid the French
through this work came back, becomes
an independent nation. In Europe,
the French aren't doing as well.
Pressure is generally the feeding
author with Ottoman support.
The feeding Russia was Swedish support
and stay on meeting with friends.
Can you let me know?
Is that of Denmark and breaks Sweden.
Russia will be free to focus on pressure
and naval battle erupts there. Denmark,
France and Denmark fighting the British
and the Swedish French are victorious.
Sweden is invaded in forced to
surrender France, Austria and Russia.
Java campaign and the
pressure feeding them.
Britain is eventually forced to surrender
after this 10 year conflict as well.
Over the next century,
Britain maintainance colonies in India,
the British Canada had been badly
wounded with liberation of Quebec.
Pressure on its ally.
German state struggled to recover.
Russia and Austria divide much of the
Polish territory and former Prussian lands
colonies develop much as I did in
our timeline in Africa and Asia.
But in the 1860 [inaudible] a long wave
of liberalism sweeps through Europe.
Poland declares its independence
from Russia and Prussia supports it.
They are largely successful in Poland,
becomes an independent nation as Austria
and France struggled with liberalism.
Countries like Serbia try to rise up from
Austria, but only the Serbian succeed.
In doing so,
France nearly engaged in civil war or
a kind of French revolution chooses
instead to become a constitutional
monarchy. And this timeline,
communism is invented,
though it's not as accepted in a Europe
that has barely experienced basic
democracy in the 20th
century war breaks out,
pressure is concerned with an ambitious
goal uniting all the Germanic lands.
It joins forces with Poland
to companies lands, France,
Austria and Russia join the other side.
Britain joins pressure as well
and this time they are victorious.
The Austrian Empire has hit the
hardest losing much of its land.
It's the pressure others to Poland
and the rest breaking up into other
independent states such as Hungary.
Frances is some of its land,
the pressure and a nation known as
Germany comes to power in the 1930s and
nationalism give voice to a new conflict.
World War One this time though,
Germany seeks to conquer all of
Europe sparked by nationalism. France,
Britain and Russia join against them.
Germany and Poland joined forces and
absorb much of the old Austrian lands.
Russia pulls out of the war is a mess
and chaos breaks out leading to the
formation of the Russian
republic and seeds,
much of its lands at the NME alliance.
Eventually though Britain and France are
victorious against the Germans and the
Polish are nations are
reduced to smaller sides,
as in many other nations
are formed from their ashes,
the republics and constitutional
monarchies. There conflict still occurred.
No cold wars happened. This timeline,
the atomic bomb was invented,
but it never actually used in combat.
The French and the British
empire continuance to 1960s
until it's social reform
and revolution calls for their ends.
United States remains a largely
isolation as nation expanding its own
territories and eventually is engaged
in its separate conflict with Japan over
the Pacific.
This could be a map of the year 2015
in which the French revolution never
occurred.
The world's superpowers or Britain,
France, Russia, America, and Japan.
Because the Japanese American war took
place before the invention of the atomic
bomb.
Japan was largely defeated,
but never successfully invaded though
was colonial possessions were gradually
lost over time. France remains a
constitutional monarchy over time.
Eventually people are given more power
in the government. Slick, modern England.
Today,
Russia as a republic,
Japan is one of the lowest
absolute monarchies in the world.
America is very strongly.
Isolation is the European Union may
occur in this timeline as well as United
Nations.
Well,
many conflicts which were resolved in
our timeline did not truly recover by the
year 2015 in this timeline.
Okay.
Also, in the 1970s the Americans,
British, French, Russians,
Japanese, each land a man on the
moon as a kind of space race occurs.
This video is made possible by
the support of Kingdom of France,
fall on Facebook for humorous
content relating to this subject.
I would encourage you to
like their page on Facebook.
Be sure to let me know what you have this
scenario in the comment section below
and let me know what you
would've done differently.
I hope you enjoyed this scenario and
for more scenarios like this history in
general,
and much more,
I would encourage you to subscribe
and check out my channel.
I think if we're watching.